[Music]
presidential candidate ron paul
released a very aggressive campaign ad
this week this is real it features
guitar solos and even barking
rottweilers it's unlike any presidential
candidate uh uh campaign i've ever seen
before this ad as i say again this is
not us this is 100 real check it out
what's up with these sorry politicians
lots of art when it's showtime
whimpering like little shih tzus you
want big cuts ron paul's been screaming
it for years budget crisis no problem
cut a trillion bucks year one that's
trillion with a t it just keeps going
and going and it's very like i've never
seen one like that yeah yeah well
apparently that ad was just the tip of
the iceberg check out ron paul's other
new ad that was released just a couple
of hours ago
i got a little deficit
put a socket in america this country
needs a budget enema and only one
candidate has the sack to get the job
done
you want cuts you got him he'll cut one
scrillion dollars of government spending
in week one that's
a skrill
department of health gone food stamps
gone regular stamps gone roads bridges
power grid god god god
then every u.s citizen will be given a
rusty pipe defend off an army of
starving marauders and a cleansing blood
will run through the streets hey america
don't be a [ __ ] vote for ron paul oh my
god he's got a chainsaw
[Music]
he's foaming at the mouth